[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de Franz 24 sobre el Éxodo Mi
nombre es Andrés Meza Muñoz y estoy aquí
en reemplazo de mi compañera Julieth
riaño
[Música]
Estados Unidos dio a conocer un nuevo
plan con el que pretende frenar el
creciente flujo de migrantes que
intentan acceder de manera ilegal y por
vía terrestre a su territorio el
presidente Joe biden dijo que permitirá
el ingreso mensual de hasta 30.000
personas provenientes de Cuba Haití
Nicaragua y Venezuela pero para ello
deben postularse en sus países de origen
y cumplir con otros requisitos el
objetivo es evitar que estos migrantes
expongan sus vidas al emprender La
Peligrosa travesía por varios países
principalmente de América Central para
los expertos las nuevas medidas implican
una serie de interminables trámites que
al final empujan a los migrantes a tomar
decisiones desesperadas en el caso de
los cubanos a seguir lanzándose al mar
para llegar a Estados Unidos veamos
los cubanos que buscan instalarse en
Estados Unidos sopesan las opciones que
tienen para migrar bajo una nueva
regulación hasta 30.000 ciudadanos de
Cuba Haití Nicaragua y Venezuela podrán
ingresar mensualmente al país y trabajar
legalmente lo que llena de optimismo a
algunos
nos ayudaría porque daría la opción de
por una vía legal
que cubanos como nosotros podamos viajar
a Estados Unidos sin necesidad de correr
grandes riesgos tratando de pasar por
diferentes países para poder llegar a la
frontera y así pero para ello deben
quedarse en sus países de origen y Desde
allí hacer la solicitud la medida
pretende evitar que miles de personas se
desplacen hasta la frontera con México
después de realizar a peligrosos viajes
a menudo organizados por traficantes de
personas otro de los requisitos es que
deben someterse a verificaciones de
antecedentes y contar con un
patrocinador en suelo estadounidense lo
que para otros resulta bastante complejo
para mí yo veo eso difícil todos los
días siempre se complica todo y bueno
Eso es para que tenga alguien allá
porque hay mucha gente así como yo que
no no tenemos a nadie afuera que que nos
patrocine ni nada de eso para los
expertos la ineficacia a la hora de
atender el alto volumen de solicitudes
sumado a estas nuevas y estrictas
medidas llevará a muchos migrantes a
recurrir a otros medios por ejemplo
lanzarse al agua con rumbo a Florida
como lo han hecho durante años
exponiendo sus vidas irónicamente una
consecuencia no deseada sería que los
cubanos en vez de volar a Nicaragua y
después intentar cruzar por
Centroamérica hasta la frontera con
México
busquen
la salida por por los medios
tradicionales es decir a través de Las
Balsas los funcionarios de Florida han
pedido al gobierno de Joe biden más
esfuerzos para disuadir a los migrantes
de realizar esta arriesgada travesía
solo durante el fin de semana de año
nuevo más de migrantes en su mayoría
cubanos llegaron a los Cayos que se
extienden a por el sur del Estado
miremos ahora la situación en Haití los
requisitos impuestos por Estados Unidos
resultan inalcanzables para muchos
residentes de La Isla que buscan huir de
la delincuencia tan solo conseguir un
pasaporte es una Odisea que implica
largos trámites en las oficinas de
migración y un valor de 50 dólares o el
doble si se hace a través de
intermediarios una cifra altísima en
esta empobrecida nación del Caribe
veamos el informe de Samuel Salgado
abandonar Haití a cualquier precio es la
premisa de miles de haitianos que hacen
largas filas frente a la única oficina
extranjería que hay en Puerto Príncipe
para obtener un pasaporte desde que el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
anunció el 8 de enero una nueva política
migratoria que le permite a 30.000
haitianos cubanos venezolanos y
nicaragüenses llegar mensualmente a
Estados Unidos por vías legales la
solicitud del documento aumentó pero
obtener el pasaporte no está al alcance
la mayoría cuesta 50 dólares un precio
exorbitante para un país donde más del
60% de su población gana menos de dos
dólares al día tengo familia en Estados
Unidos
es por eso que estoy aquí hoy para
recoger mi pasaporte y el pasaporte de
mi hijo que ya deberían habernos
entregado hace mucho tiempo
ser joven en Puerto Príncipe la capital
de Haití significa exponerse al
reclutamiento y a la violencia de las
pandillas que controlan cerca del 60% de
la ciudad según un informe de la red
Nacional de defensa de los Derechos
Humanos vivo en un país que no funciona
donde no se respeta a las personas y no
se valora a los jóvenes
Haití No está gobernado por autoridades
electas desde el magnicidio del
presidente
Julio 2021 esta ausencia del Estado ha
agravado la crisis
4,7 millones de haitianos se encuentran
en hambre extrema según Naciones Unidas
el país caribeño es uno de los países
donde más migrantes irregulares intentan
llegar a Estados Unidos según la guardia
costera más de 56 mil haitianos llegaron
al país norteamericano durante el año
fiscal 2022
la mayoría por la frontera con México y
otros en botes y Balsas
la ubicación geográfica de Haití hace
que no sea sencillo migrar hacia Estados
Unidos los haitianos deben atravesar el
mar y realizar largas y peligrosas
travesías por varios países
hasta que inmigrantes de France 24
los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el numeral migrantes
f-24 siga conectados en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]